I just wanted to take care of something
very quickly in the commercial break I
use pencils right and I notice that this
pencil hasn't been sharpened
I was just wondering can someone sharpen
this pencil for me could we get someone
I'll sharpen the pencil for you mr.
O'Brien oh thank you uh Oh Larry Larry
okay right Larry let's hear it for Larry
everybody okay let's move on with the
show there's kind of a funny news story
going around that I like I said there's
a funny news story about this weapon
come on Larry please yeah what can I do
for you okay what are you doing back
there
well I'm sharpening the pencil just like
yes okay all that isn't really necessary
can't you just use a pencil just sharpen
it with a pencil sharpener minstrel
Bryan I'm a craftsman okay nothing but
the best for you sir it's just not
necessary day you know just fine just
hurry up okay you got it sir all right
okay anyway a lot of people on the
Internet are talking about this
it's really weird news for here's your
pencil mr. O'Brien nice and sharp okay
forget the pencil what happened back
there Larry's dead
we told him to take his time that safety
comes first but he said mr. O Brien
needs this pencil sharpened ASAP he was
my best friend how long has he been
working here today was his first day but
he was the kind of guy who grows on you
fast I'm God guys this is awful and I'm
really I'm really sorry for your loss I
feel terrible about it you're not even
going to use it I'm sorry guys guys I
just want to say mr. Richter a heartfelt
thank you to you and your family for
these flowers they're beautiful it's at
least I can do Larry was such a good man
at least someone out here has a heart I
would have been happy to pitch in I
didn't know how did you order flowers so
quickly he just died without further ado
please welcome the director of the
Monterey Bay Aquarium Helen Beaumont
[Music]
thank you in addition to sharpening
pencils at the Conan show Lawrence will
Heiser was also a tireless loyal
volunteer at the aquarium and a
passionate advocate for the preservation
of the sea otter and that is why I'm
proud to announce the opening of the new
state-of-the-art Lawrence will Heiser
sea otter habitat and research
[Applause]
that's what I'm holding up look I just I
don't can't we barely knew this guy
you're right this is gone on long enough
please enjoy this short tribute video
he was a man of strength and dignity
with only one job to do he sharpens so
many pencils and they were always number
[Music]
so much your pictures laugh when you saw
touch it breaks our goddamn heart to see
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listen we're gonna take a quick break
and I'm gonna try and figure out what
the just happened
[Applause]
you